i have this tweet from political math on
twitter polymath
it's a clip from steven uh colbert's
show where he likens trump voters to the
taliban oh yeah totally yeah and
polymath says there are two options this
is a rhetorical game and people like
colbert are so frightened by reality
that they retreat to this harmless
rhetorical rhetorical marshmallow happy
land where nothing means anything or two
they're serious and they think we should
kill trump supporters that's that's a
horrifying prospect i think it's
somewhere in between um
i think it's also the idea that
with what we're saying right now right
they have this belief system they have
this belief system in the power of the
not just the power of the state but the
grace of the state the grace of the
overstates and so the taliban refuses to
believe in the grace of the state trump
supporters refuse to believe in the
grace of the states but it's you know
it's like one of those logic equations
where that that doesn't mean that they
believe the same things as this
equivalency it's a false equivalent yeah
you know i have a i have a twitter
thread i'd like to pull up and uh show
y'all guys something uh whenever there
is an apocalyptic news cycle i always
start the tweet with i don't want to set
the world on fire i just want to start a
flame in your heart which of course is a
fallout reference for those that are
fans
and it's just uh the imagery of that
song playing for those that are familiar
with fallout 3 is that you see dc in a
wasteland it's a nuclear wasteland and
it's playing this old song from i think
the 50s or something like that and
that's why i write it and i've pulled up
let's see we got here we got four we got
eight we got uh literally the entire
playlist right here there you go
i've got 16 articles i pulled up about
supply chain collapse and the reason i
pulled this up is because there's a big
story about nando's
food nando's shortage
50 restaurants were shut down in the uk
because of a chicken shortage
so i've been tracking the food shortage
story for some time
and also the food inflation story and
the one thing i've said over and over
again is that for some reason the
mainstream news cycle is not talking
about the food shortage of which there
is one and maybe for the most part you
don't notice because a shortage of of
food in certain areas just means you eat
something else because we still have a
lot of food or also it could just mean
you're paying more and slowly starting
to notice maybe you see joe biden
increase food benefits because prices
are going up that also happens and the
reason i bring this up is
after i showed these 16 articles saying
things like nando's closes 45
restaurants rogue valley restaurants
facing food shortage burger king popeye
say labor shortage and and food charges
are causing uh prices to increase
understaffed colorado restaurant so it's
not just food it's also labor i then
show this the one thing you know i love
to cite particularly over the past week
how would you rate the condition of the
national economy right now democratic
voters say 57 fairly good i did a google
search for
food shortage and it's page after page
after page all in the last week of all
these localities saying we have
shortages of this that or otherwise
chinese food restaurants across the
country have been they've been reporting
it in various jurisdictions but because
cnn doesn't say it
it must not exist and that is the
cathedral the religion these people
follow how in how could anyone who
watches the news legitimate news with a
critical mind believe the economy is
going well we had four million
resignations in april they're calling it
the great resignation they say more are
coming they say oh but look we added 950
000 or so jobs this past month but we
also have 10 million a record job
openings because people are quitting
more people are quitting we may be
adding jobs people are quitting
you've got a food shortage you've got
nando's shutting down and yet you still
have people look at this here's the best
part
during uh donald trump i think it's fair
to say
the uh the democrats believed the
economy was pretty good during donald
trump even though they didn't like the
guy i can respect that they believe that
it was fairly good not very good
but then something happened the
coronavirus stock market crashed and
there was an inversion all of a sudden
now the democrats felt everything was
bad
and do you know what date it was
january 20th that that that started to
flip what a great january 20th good
guess the moment joe buzz joe biden gets
elected
it was a little dip after election day
but after joe budden is inaugurated the
the democrats who felt the economy was
very bad plummeted and the democrats who
felt the economy was good skyrocketed
simply by virtue of having a different
president all of a sudden the economy
was good i got to say i don't think any
of those numbers have any value it
sounds like they're just voting whether
or not they like the president exactly
well but but no but think about what
that means when you look at independent
voters and republican voters they track
more
like
the truth but this also goes back to
what we were just saying when you view
your
theological belief as through the lens
of the state so you believe in the grace
of the state now i want to tease this
out a little bit more then the leader of
the state right is now also the leader
of your religion right and he preaches
right so if you're if you're you know
pope all of a sudden becomes donald
trump and you're an avowed liberal
democrat right this kind of explains
some of the reaction that you got to
that right this where it was a a
visceral emotional experience that they
had when he was elected versus a lot of
people who looked at it and said oh you
know what yeah i didn't vote that way i
guess we'll have somebody else in the
office for a term i have to imagine it
must be like being catholic and seeing
the the devil literally rise from the
ground you'd be you'd be freaking out
yes yeah well the conservatives view a
separation of church and state as in i
recognize that i have my religion and
then i have well maybe not all this is a
gross exaggeration but there's the idea
of the separation of church and state
can collapse in two different directions
you can either have the church become
the state and eat the state where you
saw a lot of the conflicts in the
medieval ages as they're prescribed by
non-literate historians and then you
have the communist example where they
dissolve the church and take on its
authorities what is the difference
between the church and the state the
state is the sword the church is the
pulpit so the church tells you what is
right but does not have the ability to
enforce it with the sword the state has
the sword but does not have the ability
to dictate to you what is right because
this state the sword is only there to
pro to
honor contracts and protect rights not
dictate morality so if i go to a pastor
and a pastor says
tithe or
don't cheat on your wife or some sort of
positive thing like you know if you need
if you want to do some good here's a you
here's some charity you can participate
in that's different than the state
coming to you and saying
uh we're you're going to do what we tell
you is good or we'll use the sword
against you and then and so you're
talking about this this pope nature yeah
these people don't believe that the
economy is bad because their savior is
in our is is there
like it's it's because joe biden but but
even even when trump was president
before kovid there was still it was over
60 percent in uh oh i'm sorry that was
obama when when uh yeah
hold on hold on sorry i'm looking at one
part sorry he's just
from france i guess i'm confused all the
time
from 60
down to 40 before covet so it was
between 40 and 60 percent of democrats
felt the economy was fairly good under
donald trump i mean 40 is still pretty
high right right right right right right
right right right let's prefer that i
don't want to make it seem like right
you know under obama it was like 65
thought the economy was very good donald
trump got elected there was a little
drop off which is kind of hilarious but
a little one and it stayed around 60 for
a little bit for a little bit and then
went down to 50 about you know a year
later and then down to 40. and then
covet happened it hits the bottom
and then binding it's elected and it
goes right back up so if we're using
this as a measure of statistics it's a
set of facts not evaluations how would
we evaluate the decisions the people who
what are we trying to evaluate here are
we trying to evaluate the opinion the
the
validity of the opinions of the people
who changed their um opinion on the
economy based on well let me let me put
it this way if uh if i said
to an independent or a republican
do you think it is going to rain
they would look up at the sky and say
you know
that does look like a storm cloud
i think it might rain i would give it a
30 chance you get 100 you know
independents and 100 republicans and you
ask them and they'll give you relatively
similar answers the independents lean
more towards more optimistic it's
probably going to be a little sunny
it'll clear up but they all look and
then you get about 40 i think i think
actually the um
the
plurality of negative is like 68 to 70
percent of independence and republicans
believe the economy is bad so they're
all looking up and they're going that's
that's a storm cloud it's probably going
to rain and some are like i don't know i
think it'll clear and then you ask
democrats and instead of looking up at
the sky they look down at their phones
and then they scroll through twitter and
they say no rain better check cnn oh no
cnn says it's not gonna cnn says it's
not raining so it's not raining and
you're like but there's a cloud in the
sky yes yeah so the governor of
minnesota is governor walls also
colloquially known as lord walls
declares
yeah it's great lord wallace declares
that today no one shall be doing indoor
dining
that's what de blasio's doing yes that's
exactly the same although wilhelm yeah
wilhelm is demanding your papers
that's his name what's the name warren
wilhelm
with
would it sound too cool to call de
blasio kaiser wilhelm no we should
definitely do that 100 cars
kaiser yes kaiser we will absolutely
show our papers you know the thing about
new york is that you need your id to get
in
let alone the vaccine passport no id
sorry so that's what that's like 70
percent of the black community in new
york can't go inside buildings anymore
but you know what you know you know what
honestly though i'm willing to bet up in
like the bronx and harlem they're not
checking
what are they going to do they don't
have the means to do it like what i mean
by that like if i'm going into a like a
corner store or like a bodega or
something are they really going to sit
there and i don't think you need it for
that not not for that but like like a
sit down restaurant but that could be
taco bell what about a stand it's not
going to be fair
you're allowed to walk into a restaurant
for takeout so takeout's fine right
right so what i mean by the means is
that these restaurants have to hire
someone to sit at the door and do
vaccine checks now
so like when you're carrying someone at
a bar yeah and so the most most of the
places that have the ability to do this
are like in manhattan they're not in
central brooklyn or you know uh
south brooklyn or uh it's not flatbush
avenue yeah yeah yeah i mean probably in
the hipster areas do you where it's do
you want to go into business with me i
want to start a business where we just
vaccine check and we only take bribes
yes this sounds lucrative actually you
know afghanistan it'll be called
vaccination you might want to regret
that because i'm willing to bet a
company will pop up in new york right
now
that says we we do vaccine checks and
they contract to all the businesses
and then right they could easily have 30
000 employees in a week i'm looking
forward to the the the black market
that's going to rise up like the the
prohibition market like we saw with
alcohol the the speaking restaurants and
basements yes all the the groups
organizations of speakeasies that are
gonna now it's gonna be a genre it's
gonna be an industry it's good right
yeah dude prop uh it did so much damage
to the american people and and the
economy and everything trying to
prohibit alcohol like haven't we learned
our lesson we see what prohibiting weed
has done to society you want to talk
about group psychosis you remove the
weed and make people feel bad for it so
you want you want to here's the silver
lining to that so today is the 18th of
august
2021 today's the last day for comment on
the atf's attempt to redefine what a
receiver is for a firearm they're trying
to go after 80 lowers and while today's
the last day to comment on it so if you
haven't please do um
and you can find more of that on
recoilweb.com if you have to shameless
plug but here's the here's the here's
the silver lining we just we just
watched the american government so great
and powerful that it be
uh accidentally lose a bunch of belt fed
machine guns night vision equipment
silence silencers suppressors rifles two
[ __ ] helicopters helicopters
taliban have to pay a class three tax
yeah
you know on any nfa right you know
regularly you're going after them for
decades but so like so so here's the
solute part of that solution in the
silver lining is stop taking the clowns
seriously
right so when when
um
when david chipman they're trying to
appoint david chipman as the head of the
atf he's that mass child murder isn't he
he was a participant in waco
so yes and and
children were murdered at wink
there you go yes i also don't want him
to show up at my house tomorrow oh okay
by the way
not only unrepentant uh he's he a
celebratory participant yeah i mean oh
yeah he went on reddit
and and defended it to the hilt to the
hilt yeah about waco not even not even a
question of you know oh my gosh i wish
it hadn't gone that way but you know we
had our the situation situation just
straight up lied yeah about the people
actually you were uh telling us a good
story before we went off it's not
exactly a story but it's a really
spurious connection of events so it's
what he did it's what he said yeah right
so uh wii u shot a firearm the first
time i came out here we shot one of your
firearms it was a beretta m82 barrett
barrett ain't sorry yeah barrett m82 50
caliber
semi-automatic i know i'm supposed to
get my numbers right
what's the name right those are words
so we shot a barrett m82 and the origin
a friend of mine who was at gunsmith
this week informed me on the origins
of the barrett m82
so back in the days when the mujahideen
were fighting against the russians
the americans created the barrett m82 to
use a common anti-vehicular round that
was they'd been around for a while which
was the 50 caliber round and they put it
into a sniper rifle that was
semi-automatic so you have to pull the
trigger and then pull the trigger again
so it's no fully automatic every you
have to pull the trigger to shoot you
around
and the advantage of that firearm was
that it could be used to take out
certain russian helicopters that were
bothered plaguing afghanistan
so that kind of gets ingrained in the
cultural history of the firearm and then
a couple of years later a decade and a
year later
there's waco
and what happens at waco supposedly
according to david chipman somebody shot
down a helicopter with a plane with a
sniper rifle which would have been a
barrett and he all he's got to say is
they had a barrett so they shot down on
a helicopter and he can go in front of
the american people digitally and in
voice
outright lie to them
that
people at waco shot down a plane with a
bear at 50 calories this is what he just
had on reddit this is exactly how he
went on reddit and yeah i was making
this argument yeah that's not true yeah
it's not even completely not just how
did a helicopter get shot down there
there was a helicopter that crashed
if i'm not mistaken but it was not
related to it yeah my understanding is
it didn't happen yeah it just no it
completely didn't happen but what your
point is though is that he was using
this sort of cultural history yep of the
weapons platform in order to basically
you know not not even deduce but just
sort of like i'm gonna connect
manipulate the narrative so that people
would think that this helicopter had
been shot down by them simply because
they had a certain weapons platform or
he could even say well they must have
wanted to shoot down helicopters because
what else would you use a barrett for
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you